hey guys what he called James gun when
he puts out disgusting tweets James dog
oh man James done I don't know if it's
appropriate to make a joke about what's
going on with this um oh well I don't
know either but I think it's at least
reasonable to assume you may be good
guys I don't know if you heard the news
looks like James gun has been fired at
Disney Disney is with Marvel as you all
know so you know the video is not about
this I'm kind of curious if they're
gonna take the guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 script because you put out a tweet
or an Instagram picture I forget that he
had a script I don't know if they're
gonna take that script or gonna just do
something we're like we don't know
anymore you know I don't know here's
what I do know
I found the tweets and I was like whoa
had zero clue that he had made these
kind of tweets now everything is about
context everything is about perspective
on certain situations and examining it
and I am in no way here going to defend
the tweets that he put out because they
are pretty I don't I'm not gonna read
from them they're very they're jokes in
in rather poor taste
jokes in poor taste a lot of them deal
with us joking about minors pedophilia
jokes they're pretty vulgar very vulgar
jokes and especially the fact that
they're a tweet you can either stand up
comic make a certain joke but there's a
lot of different context behind it
you're watching a comedian you know and
even sometimes nowadays no stand-up
comic and even make a joke and get a lot
of backlash for a joke they make on
stage a tweet with no tone no real
additional context leading up to this
sentence or sentences that you put out
it's just the listener hearing it a
certain way it's like when I read it I
was like oh these are these are nasty
because they're disgusting joke
that's how I felt when I read it even
though they're obviously just jokes I
get the decision that has been made I
get the decision I am actually not at
all surprised that he tweeted these
things and I'm more just like I know
where James Gunn came from so none of
this is surprising to me and I'm sort of
surprised that he made it into the
Disney building at all without them is
kind of acknowledging like he's from
Troma he wrote Romeo and Julia and like
Troma is the home of all things you know
off-color and taboo and wild and wacky
that's why I was bringing up comedians
specifically because James Gunn prior to
go even with what he's done with
guardians I've always associated him as
like a really edgy type of comic writer
yeah and he does have a certain teenage
boy sensibility to some of his jokes and
and you know more of the earlier stuff
where it's very explicit but you know
that carries through his work even up to
today there's obviously gonna be two
sides that are gonna be presented to
what's happening right now
one side is these are old tweets let it
go that's one side that will be
presented the other side is no that's
not right you know let another white man
get off food just say whatever he wants
and I think I'm more on the side of you
got to accept the consequences of what
happened for your action so it makes
sense to me what's happened it's not
everything is meant to just be joked
about
well this is a lesson too about living
in the giant archive that we all inhabit
now is like these are tweets from some
of them are from 2009 even and stuff
just stays there and people don't always
know he put up a tweet before deleting
his account basically saying like I have
grown a lot and changed a lot as a
person over the years and that's a fair
thing to say but you know like a tweet
is just immortalized in a little box and
can be taken out of context and out of
its time frame at any moment and that's
what happened here you know so I can't
blame Disney and all for for cutting
ties I'm just still a little surprised
that they had no idea this could happen
with him because it's James Gunn I don't
know if they were completely oblivious
it would happen with him you see the
thing is I'm all for maybe he is a
different guy and he's thrown a lot for
you guys who can sometimes be confused
by when
you watch our older videos and I used to
go by name Ryan right mm-hmm Ryan right
the idea of that alter ego was to make
as many to include as many offensive
perverted jokes it wasn't every video
but as many as I could throughout the
week
you know borderline sexist jokes
borderline racist jokes and that's why I
went by an alter ego name because once I
switch to just being me some people
might not notice a difference but I
think what you'll notice if you really
pay attention is I'm not really that
pervert in real life there's a reason
why a lot of girls are keep coming on
the channel because off camera I wasn't
really a pervert hey you know you don't
just go around poking everybody yeah
something's a similar effect he's like
you know I used to fancy myself a
provocateur I used to love to dabble in
the taboo but ya thought I was gonna get
a rise out of her yeah buddy so I get
what his past might be and prior to the
whole me to movement and all those
things I stopped doing the whole ride
right stick for several reasons a major
reason that I was a con play for a long
time was have a sick of being known as
this guy wherever I went in my personal
life
well I would go places and I would be
just being known as this guy and I'm not
gonna go through every single video over
the years where I made a joke that was
so edgy as Ryan write and take it down
or whatever I don't remember a lot of
him but even not long ago there was a
video that I put up at the very
beginning of the real rejects called why
women have it better than men and it's a
very just stupid jokey video like I'm
coming up with reasons that are
obviously just so not true but the idea
of Ryan Wright was to say it with as
much conviction as poss like they're
dumb reasons yeah that's the satire like
one of the reasons was if I'm having a
threesome with two girls I can't use
both crotches at the same time but a
girl can use them like it's obviously
stupid stuff but I said it would like
conviction that's the satire of it and
then I saw a comment coming and I
realized I responded differently to this
comment in my own life than how I used
to which was that's just a joke it's
funny like I wouldn't even reply back to
a keeper saying oh you're just a joke
be so sensitive cuz I've kind of grown
into a person that's like sensitivity is
actually a strength and sensitivity is
necessary right now I rather be overly
sensitive than insensitive if I'm gonna
sway to one side of the argument I feel
like that's the cultural argument right
now because I think our sensitivities
are very high right now ah yeah as a
society all of our nerves are on but I
am kind of of the mind that yes while
that can sometimes lead to extreme kind
of knee-jerk reactions I would rather we
go this direction and then balance out
versus the opposite direction and not
find her I'm not saying be oversensitive
and then lead that to anger and
hostility saying just be more sensitive
to other people's feelings and then a
more aware of other people woman
commented on that video it's like a
month ago or something and said like wow
you're such a sexist and immediately I
was like you know what I'm gonna
apologize there because I was like
you're you're right even those videos
years old I don't go by this riot right
dude anymore and I don't joke like this
at all anymore at least this anymore I
was like that's not me and I feel bad
because I've offended her and I
apologized and then I took down the
video this is the thing I'm like when I
I'm not gonna go here to tat James gun
and go what you said it's just like it
is disgusting what he said but I'm not
gonna ridicule him as a human being
because I'm sure you go back to some of
my old videos maybe I said some [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] up when I was doing
the riot right stick yeah I definitely
don't love I definitely don't appreciate
a lot of different aspects about James
Gunn's sense of humor but I'm not
sitting here like I hate you I hope you
die you know because this is a grand
example of you should really think
before you tweet especially now I'm the
thing that concerns me most about this
is I'm just like why do you have such a
fixation on pedophilia in your jokes
like that is like the read that's the
worrisome yeah that's what yeah that's
the worrisome thing the jokes themselves
I'm just like dude like calm down and
yeah it's just like you made your bed
and now you gotta sleep in it man yeah
so I completely understand it's not the
same thing as what Robert Downey jr. did
Robert Downey jr. had this really bad
criminal path
being a drug addict and all these things
and Disney could easily go you know look
at your past it's don't fly well oh well
this but it's a different thing because
he was just harming himself I don't
really know the details of the story I
don't know if you harmed other people or
whatever I don't but from what it's been
in the public perspective is he was his
self harming himself with his drug
addiction anyway that doesn't fly under
Disney umbrella that's a good thing
wholesome yeah this is you know this is
Disney talk about molesting kids and
stuff like this is a whole whole more
sensitive subject right now and I mean
it's totally not gonna fly with any of
their sensibilities and image like I get
where Disney's coming from with this and
I also get I get his argument and I do
get the sense that yeah he has grown up
over time and the sad thing is you just
forget about the stupid [ __ ] you said
before and now also the stupid [ __ ] has
a different role in society than it ever
did so and I think it should yeah yeah
it's a difference is it should I'll hear
comics sometimes to talk about how word
a culture that's a lot more
hypersensitive and I'm like that's kind
of a good thing though because we have
movements that are very relevant and
important it's good for the bigger PA
there are certain fun little things that
get maybe trampled along the way or
maybe responded a bit too harshly too
but for the grand better good of society
yeah I think it is a good thing to be
sensitive and to be awake and aware so
that we can make the world better and
then go back to joking about [ __ ] you
know yeah there's been a lot of talk
that I've been opening up my mind to of
the art versus the artists mmm the
debate for the longest time I would lean
more towards like well yeah just
separate your [ __ ] self dude like
Tara I used to just lean just watch her
Roman Polanski yeah I used to be there
and I'll mid that and I'm more at this
point in my life now where I'm like well
we can't just keep doing that that's not
okay I think that maybe he has changed
it's like I don't know who James Gunn is
I don't know if he's maybe like he made
some [ __ ] up jokes years ago that were
public I don't know if he's still jokes
like that when the
murrs aren't on him or i don't know if
he jokes like that once he signed with
Disney like I don't know bottom line is
I totally get why Disney did this yeah I
feel like that's the at least for me
that's kind of the only conclusion I can
draw as I understand this whole
situation how it came to be how the
decisions were made and I can't really
argue with it you know and art from the
artist is one of the few defining
debates right now in the public sphere
and that's like the trickiest thing
because there is a certain amount of
it's always gonna be I've heard this
point before so I'm gonna ape it here
it's always gonna be a little bit
arbitrary where you draw the line
because I don't think there's any place
that everyone will agree on but yeah
it's like when you find out that the
artist who makes your beloved art maybe
is not such a savory person or maybe has
some destructive points of view or does
destructive things for me anyway as a
consumer of media
it's that awareness once it enters my
mind is is in the art it's just there
yeah so I mean this to me isn't horrible
enough that I might never watch another
James Gunn movie the way like a Roman
Polanski situation I'm like I don't
think that like yeah yeah bad tweets are
bad and I certainly like James Gunn is
just problematic to me there are things
I like about him there are things I
don't like about him yeah it's a
fascinating debate I don't think we need
to go find him and burn him or anything
like know you know but yeah I mean I can
certainly understand if you don't want
to support James Gunn anymore I don't
think yeah I don't think his career is
exactly ruined no he's just not a fit
for Disney I was astonished when they
get the first place yeah it was like you
know cool for him but also really and he
answered the spectrum of the geekdom
community before guardians as like
really edgy [ __ ] yeah yeah and really
taboo really wild like don't make these
jokes anymore and you're not a fit for
Disney anymore just move on cuz yeah
another news Joss Whedon is taking over
Gardens yeah the more acceptable version
of screwing I yeah I don't know I mean I
feel like the art from the artist line
is just everyone's to draw at a certain
point be
cuz I bet there are some people out
there who can just understand that this
piece of art is beyond a person you know
cuz a person like bad people make good
art all the time and good people make
bad art all the time you know it's
another point I'm aping from elsewhere
but that's also true so it's like that's
it's just such a hard argument yeah you
know and I think it's just up to
everybody to figure it out for
themselves and move forward and and
really the crucial element is just
deciding who to support monetarily who
to sustain by consuming their art yeah
all right guys well subscribe for more
videos like that notification babble
don't tweet anything pedophilic